[Music]
at the beginning of season two we meet
alex in a very serene place all of the
pain and the frustration that she had
been carrying around for years and years
and years
i think she had to get out of the chaos
bradley's doing anything to say that she
is compliant she's ready to be a team
player but she also wants autonomy
she thinks she's in control and we find
out by the end of episode one that is
such an illusion
you could have been my friend but that
did not happen
and i'm so glad it did not because all
you had to do was be honest with me
at the end of season one there was an
enormous thrill that corey and bradley
shared in that cory's attachment to her
grew in a way that was unexpected to him
we don't know if it's just an
infatuation or it's real but they are
always doing this dance around each
other cameras hey mark
coming into the second season was really
a different trip because
we came in and shot during covid we were
all
very excited to be going back into
production but also very scared
we'd already started a season two that
then suddenly felt less relevant
when i read the new episode one for
season two where you start to feel all
those little things that we were not
aware of then the little sharing of food
the little sneezes just thought that was
very smart
we shot a big big new year's eve
sequence in l.a we did times square as
you would outside of a gigantic parking
lot and so basically large enough for
huge green screen signs it was really
fun to shoot it and then create the
world with vfx
standby camera two
the dance number was great and they only
rehearsed it once an hour before we shot
because we wanted it to look not
rehearsed
to do that on one of my first days on
set especially while we were filming
during a pandemic to just have unbridled
joy it was so funny i couldn't stop
laughing on the day
everybody was like 20 20 is my year it
was surreal to go back and shoot the
arrogance we all had on that day in
december of 2019.
to carrie's credit she really
came up with an incredible storyline
about
what happens
when the world
closes in while you're just making plans
for your own life
[Music]